so we're talking about this and yeah you
know and there are some merits what
they're saying not a lot but there's
some merits why is it so dangerous why
can't we just say look you know if these
people have these ideas that's fine and
they're more than welcome to them and
you should read some of the accounts
there they're charming online where
somebody's you know talking about the
challenges of trials and tribulations of
raising a gender-neutral child they
decide that they're going to raise their
child without any reference to gender
identity they're you know they're always
gonna they're not gonna put them in blue
or pink or whatever the different things
trucks enjoy and they're like why is my
little girl always choosing dolls no
matter how many times I buy her a truck
or why is she putting a dress on the
truck you know we try not to have
gendered behavior and she just keeps
choosing it what do I do
she must be picking it up from society
everywhere so then when you start to how
is it so dangerous I don't I don't know
how trying to force something on
somebody that doesn't match whatever
their proclivities are doesn't result in
something that's at least suboptimal
like I grew up in the southeastern US
which is a little bit behind the times
and so in the Bible maybe I don't know
if you've read that book it's an
interesting
hey man I'm from Russia we're still
living in that you may know that they
mentioned it's like 27 times that being
left-handed is a sin it's something that
was sinister or whatever so I actually
know one person who because he was born
left-hand it had his left hand tied to
his body until he was something like
seven years old for most things
especially when he was at school or
having to do writing tasks she had to
learn how to use his right hand even
though he's left-handed and there's been
some study there's enough people that
have gone through this to where there's
been been some studies on these people
and what you find is find out is that
they're almost always as adults
ambidextrous so you can use both hands
very well the thing is is that all the
evidence we have points to the the idea
that they will never
as good with either of their hands as
they would have been with their left
hand if you just leaned in to write what
their natural proclivity was and so
there's the threat there of when you're
limiting people limiting people yeah the
other there are further threats of
course which is if you think that the
the mechanism for something is if you
have the wrong diagnosis for the the
disease the prescription you get is
probably going to be wrong so if the
prescription if you believe that oh my
child won't conform to the non gender
roles that I was trying to force upon
him or her what do I do it must be
society now you have this mission well I
have to break society because it's
perverting my child and so at that point
you you're limiting your child
potentially which you also get bent on
this mission that tries to break apart
the structures of society but if the
structures in society have some
correlation to the same underlying
problems that you see it problems that
you're seeing in your child you can't
break them without forcing it on people
when you start forcing it on people all
kinds of weird stuff happens
[Music]